inflation galopante non seulement aux
états unis mais aussi chez nous en
europe
pour la france l'insee l'estimé à 5% sur
un an un peu plus que le mois précédent
à l'heure où la forte reprise post
pandémie créer des pénuries sur
certaines matières premières allons nous
connaître une hausse généralisée des
prix le phénomène est-il passagers ou
peut-il s'inscrire dans la durée on voit
ça tout de suite avec un économiste
jacques sapir
c'est notre rubrique milito n'est pas en
un an au mois de juin jacques évidemment
alors jacquin quand on parle évidemment
d'inflation c'est à dire de au sein des
prix de quoi parle-t-on exactement
oui bonjour stéphanie alors oui
effectivement on est aujourd'hui
confronté à une hausse des prix qui est
de l'ordre de 1,4 1,5 pour cent en tant
que tel ce n'est pas énorme mais ça
reste néanmoins significatifs et alors
surtout le problème que l'on se pose
c'est de savoir est ce que cette hausse
des prix qui semble lier effectivement à
des déséquilibres entre l'offre et la
demande
au fait que la demande est redémarré
plus vite que l'offre notamment et bien
est ce que ces déséquilibres vont être
passager auquel cas n'y a pas de raison
de s'inquiéter
ou bien vont-ils devenir plus
structurelle et là effectivement cela
demanderait un ajustement de la
politique économique
injac pour commencer cody lindsay sur
l'évolution de l'inflation
alors c'est un peu intéressants l'insee
indique que l'inflation qui avait
tendance à baisser et qui avaient des
c'est d'ailleurs assez fortement depuis
le début de 2010 9 jusqu'à atteindre un
point relativement bas en 2020 et bien
cette inflation a recommencé à augmenter
à la fin de 2020 et elle augmente
extrêmement vite
au point que aujourd'hui en juin elle a
atteint son niveau de 2010 1 et l'on
peut craindre effectivement que cette
inflation continue d'augmenter et
puissent atteindre les 2
% pourquoi pas les deux ennemis % fin
2020 ou en 2021
donc ça c'est une dimension du problème
mais alors quelles sont les raisons
rênes de cette hausse alors une des
premières raisons c'est l'envolée des
prix des matières premières il faut
savoir que l'ensemble des matières
premières aujourd'hui par à la hausse
alors que ce soit l'énergie
on voit bien le prix du pétrole a
nettement augmenté aujourd'hui le
pétrole se négocie autour de 74 75
dollars le baril mais il ya aussi les
produits alimentaires à ce qu'on appelle
les matières premières agricoles
et là c'est plus qu'une eau est pris il
ya des phénomènes de pénurie qui
existent et qui pose aujourd'hui des
vrais problèmes pour l'approvisionnement
dans toute une série de pays ça risque
d'ailleurs de provoquer des émeutes de
la faim
et puis il ya les métaux industriels
tous ses produits en fait sont inclus
dans les produits manufacturés que nous
consommons évidemment les matières
premières agricoles servent à faire nos
aliments et puis les métaux sont dans
les produits manufacturés comme les
automobiles les lakers électroménager
quant à l'énergie
voilà tout le monde quand il passe à la
pompe dans la semaine peut vérifier que
le prix de l'essence a nettement
augmenté depuis ces dernières semaines
et la question évidemment qu'on se pose
c'est donc bien cette hausse des
matières premières
alors ya trois raisons fondamentalement
il ya trois raisons la première raison
c'est que la demande a augmenté beaucoup
plus vite que l'offre n'a pu repartir
alors la demande a augmenté évidemment
en chine mais aussi aux états unis donc
ça c'est un premier problème la deux le
deuxième problème c'est la hausse des
prix du commerce maritime
ce qu'on appelle par exemple l' indice
baltic dry qui mesurent la tension si
vous voulez sur le commerce maritime et
bien cet indice baltic dry
il est reparti à la hausse depuis grosso
modo juin 2
il vint et aujourd'hui il est à son
niveau le plus haut depuis 2014
donc ça c'est un poids qui va évidemment
dans le sens d'un accroissement du prix
de toutes les matières premières qu'il
faut bien transporter la troisième
raison est bien c'est la désorganisation
des chaînes logistiques qui n'ont pas
encore récupéré de la crise de l'aco
vide et cette désorganisation que l'on
avait pensé d'abord être de très courte
durée d envoi qu'elle va durer au moins
jusque fin 2020 voix 2021 elles font on
n'assiste pas aussi à une hausse des
produits manufacturés vac oui tout à
fait et pour les mêmes raisons en
réalité sur les produits manufacturés
on voit que là aussi la hausse de la
demande elle est plus rapide que le
redémarrage de l'offre bien sûr l'offre
va finir par redémarrer un mais pour
l'instant il ya un déséquilibre offre
demande qui est évident il y à aussi
justement ce problème du transport
cette hausse des coûts de transport et
puis il ya évidemment cette
désorganisation des chaînes logistiques
donc tout cela fait qu'il y a
aujourd'hui des tendances haussières à
la fois sur les matières premières et
sur les produits manufacturés
on peut penser et je crois que c'est
assez raisonnable de le penser que en
cela va se terminer que vers la fin 2022
les choses vont revenir à la normale
néanmoins ça veut dire qu'il y aura un
pic d'inflation il y aura un coût
d'inflation de la fin de 2020
au début disons à la fin du premier
semestre 2021 jacques pour l'instant
vous n'avez pas évoquer des fennecs vous
n'avait évoqué que des phénomènes de
l'économie réelle est ce à dire que les
injections de mode et non pas simulé
l'inflation vous avez tout à fait raison
de poser cette question
stéphanie parce que oui c'est un c'est
un vrai problème alors on le sait les
banques centrales ont injecté beaucoup
d'argent dans les économies que ce soit
aux états unis la réserve fédérale que
ce soit en europe la banque centrale
européenne pour justement soutenir
l'activité
au moment de la crise de la corrida au
moment de la période et confinement le
problème c'est qu'une partie de cet
argent n'a pas été bien distribués
si vous voulez il ya des catégories
sociales de la population qui n'ont pas
du tout vu je dirais la couleur de cet
argent d'autres qui ont d'une certaine
manière vu la majorité de cet argent
arriver sur leur compte et concrètement
ça se traduit par deux phénomènes
le premier phénomène c'est la hausse des
cours boursiers si vous voulez c'est cet
argent va s'investir sur les marchés
financiers évidemment on sait bien que
c'est pas l'ensemble de la population
qui joue sur les marchés financiers
c'est une très petite couche qui joue
sur les marchés financers donc ça c'est
déjà un premier effet de l'injection
d'eau des études le deuxième effet
équipe extrêmement important c'est la
hausse des prix de l'immobilier est ce
que l'on constate c'est que cette hausse
des prix de l'immobilier
elle est aujourd'hui général dans
l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
vous savez y être des pays où cette
hausse elle a atteint 18% sur un an
bon la france est plutôt en retard de ce
côté là mais avec 9 % quand même donc ça
veut dire que ce que l'on appelle les
actifs patrimoniaux grosso modo les
actions les obligations mais surtout les
actions et les biens immobiliers sont en
train de flamber
et ça ça pose un problème pour le budget
des ménages parce que aujourd'hui
imaginer un ménage qui doit changer
d'appartement parce qu'il a des enfants
un nouvel enfant vient d'arriver dans le
foyer ou tout simplement parce que le
travail impose le changement si vous
voulez d'appartement ou de maison et
bien à ce moment-là ce ménage va être
amené à surpayer l'acquisition d'une
maison ou d'un appartement est donc
évidemment ça va peser lourdement sur le
budget des ménages
en conclusion à jacques on aurait donc
non pas une inflation mais plusieurs
oui tout à fait on est en réalité
confronté à deux inflation qui sont
distincts et la véritable question c'est
de savoir est ce qu'elle ne pourrait pas
ce combi
et en un seul mouvement inflationnistes
on a d'un côté l'inflation qui vient je
dirais de facteurs réels
donc c'est le déséquilibre entre la
demande et le redémarrage de la
production leur démarrage de l'offre
tomber sap
on voit bien que ça ne va pas durer
éternellement c'est une question qui
sera réglé un pire à la fin 2022
bon il ya le problème aussi des coûts de
transport de la désorganisons mais tous
ces problèmes sont normalement appelées
à se régler d'ici un an à à 18 mois
et puis il ya un autre problème c'est le
problème justement des conséquence de
l'injection de monnaie dans les
économies qui fait flamber les actifs
patrimoniaux qui fait flamber les prix
du logement au point d'ailleurs que la
banque centrale européenne réfléchit à
intégrer les prix du logement dans son
indice des prix et ça ça pose évidemment
un problème très important pour le
sauver pour le budget des ménages
alors la question que l'on doit se poser
c'est est-ce que c'est 2 d'inflation
resteront séparés et à ce moment là il y
aura pas de véritable problème puisque
on voit bien que l'inflation réelle qui
est pour l'instant la plus forte qui est
celle qui pour l'instant portes d'une
certaine manière l indice des prix
on voit bien qu'elle va s'essouffler fin
enfin disons début 2022 voire fin 2022
ou bien est-ce que cette inflation va se
combiner avec l'inflation monétaire qui
pour l'instant ne touche que les actifs
patrimoniaux et dans ce cas là elle
pourrait effectivement s'inscrire dans
la durée
à suivre donc dans les mois qui viennent
jacques mercier est là